hello everyone and welcome to a video
long overdue but I've been really under
the weather lately and I couldn't record
my voice uh wasn't working but as some
of you have already started wondering if
I'm alive I decided to throw in a video
Even though I I was planning on relaxing
for a few more days uh but I did not
finish
um The Saga of the final so the speed
chess championship between Magnus
Carlsen and Hikaru Nakamura and it was
it was one of the most thrilling matches
I have ever seen and if you guys haven't
seen it do check out the original
footage on chess.com in some three hours
but you will enjoy every every second of
it because uh the it's um the same as
every match in the speeches Championship
first an hour and a half of um uh five
plus one then 60 Minutes of three plus
one and then 30 minutes of one plus one
the uh the the slowish bullet and these
are the the the scores of every time uh
format so in five plus one Hikaru beat
Magnus Within incredible result of six
and a half to two and a half then Magnus
retaliated in the three plus one but
only with a result of six to four and
then in the OnePlus One segment Magnus
one with a result of five to four but it
was uh
uh it was so intense uh so so Hikaru had
a four four point margin uh going into
three plus one then Magnus lowered it to
two and then in the bullet section
Magnus equalized at some point but then
he car won two games Magnus won another
one and then uh this was uh I'm gonna
show it to you uh interestingly Magnus
switched shirts after he lost so badly
in the five plus one section so he
switched shirts for the three plus one
section I thought maybe it would bring
him more luck and it did but uh uh yeah
this is the position uh here of the
final game they played so if if Magnus
manages to win this one and he is up a
queen for the moment even though his
Queen is hanging but even after this
check you Hikaru is getting checkmated
in a few moves uh but the entire match
can only last up to three hours and that
clock ran out before Magnus could finish
checkmating Hikaru even though he still
had time on his clock for the actual
game but those are the uh the the rules
of the event and okay some of you have
been saying that hikaru's been using uh
bleeding way too much at some point
Hikaru had a lost position and then he
had two minutes on the clock and then he
just allowed the two minutes to run out
but that's all within the rules you can
use those tactics uh to gain the upper
hand and Essie CaRu said he feels like
he will have to use every possible
advantage to win against Magnus Carlsen
uh but yeah he caught hikar won the
match with a one point margin it was
absolutely incredible uh do watch the
entire thing if you don't watch an
entire three hours uh you will not be
able to fully appreciate this match as I
will only show you one game from the
five plus one section uh it's the one
that I thought was um the the the the
most enjoyable uh so let's dive straight
into it so he car with the white pieces
opens with D4 we have Knight to F6
Knight to F3 and now Pawn to G6 with C4
and now Bishop to G7 uh Magnus goes for
the king's Indian defense uh one of the
uh one of the openings that Hikaru is
very well known for so Knights the C3 we
have castles uh e for nd6 so very
standard stuff here nothing out of the
ordinary Bishop to D3 Bishop to E2 is
much more played here so Hikaru looking
to mix it up here Bishop D3 Knight B to
D7 H3 and now uh here uh E5 is known C5
is known A6 is known but A5 is unknown
so already as of move seven we have a
completely new game aimed at stopping
that White's Advantage uh expansion on
the queen side you know that in the
king's Indian defense black wants to
expand on the Kings and attack the white
king white will count Hunter by
advancing his pawns on the queen side so
this is aimed directly at stopping that
Bishop to G5 Hikaru continues
development H6 now with Bishop to E3 and
now Magnus strikes in the center Ponte
E5 and now D5 now it's very interesting
here if Hikaru goes Queen to D2 what is
happening
it's a very complicated line and that's
why I think Hikaru avoided it even
though it should be very good for white
let's say he captures Knight captures
and now you play Rook the E8 you allow
the H Pawn to be captured but if Bishop
captures some H6 and Bishop captures
Queen captures there's Knight the C5 and
now the the pawn on e4 is attacked three
times and also the bishop and D3 is
hanging so black would have very very
nasty counter play here so that's why
Hikaru goes for the standard stuff he
advances the pawn in the center Pawn to
D5 Knight to C5 and now Bishop the C2 we
have knighted the H5 and G3 and you will
see how this G3 move will come in handy
uh very very very quickly another
question is and always this is the
question can black execute F5 and here
it would be a bit premature I will just
show it just to give you an example of
what's happening let's say he captures
Bishop captures nargon playing Knight to
H4 put pressure on the bishop and the G6
pawn and after Bishop captures Queen
captures G5 you will win this beautiful
F5 square foot your night that's of
course if black plays this um to
absolute perfection which is not the
case more often than not but white would
be okay even if black did now let's say
queen D7 you attack the Knight G4 and if
Knight to F4 you can simply Play Bishop
captures and c5d characters and castles
Queen side and white would have this
incredible position with a monster
Knight on F5 and black never having the
option of playing B5 because white just
controls the square too much so that's
what you would get so that's why Magnus
continues development the bishop to D7
Queen to D2 and now King to H7 we have
Castles by Hikaru and now Pawn to A4
with ideas of A3 King to B1 by Hikaru
and now Magnus goes for Queen to F6 he
puts pressure on the F3 Knight even
though A3 is definitely a viable option
for example A3 B3 Knight A6 you're going
to shift the Knight over to B4 and black
will have very
a nice pressure but okay after King to
B1 we have Queen to F6 going after the
Knight and the mag uh Hikaru defends it
with Queen back to E7 and now Knight to
H4 by Hikaru and here Magnus played Rook
after B8 getting ready to bust open the
position on the queen side uh the
problem is the position is now
completely winning for Hikaru but it is
up to you to figure out how he can do
that so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
Hikaru while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
offer uh amazing night offering and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Knight to F5 absolutely
incredible and uh if you let the engine
crunch the numbers here just I mean it's
a Blitz game of course you can't
possibly calculate everything uh but
even if you allow the engine to Crunch
the numbers like let's say the depth 45
uh the engine will say Okay grab the
Knight but it's still bad for black
because this is just an amazing position
for example G captures Queen captures an
H5 you can never play F4 that's why the
G3 move comes in handy and if black
starts attacking on the queen side which
is Black's only option then you're just
gonna capture and okay now you've
prepared the the advancement so you can
start capturing let's say captures
captures Queen captures on F5 with check
and after King G8 look at this bishop D3
forces The Rook away from the fifth rank
Rook B7 and now you're gonna capture the
Knight captures captures in Rook D2 and
you never have to worry about other
thing A3 is now met with B3 and once you
put the bishop on C4 there is nothing
black can do to to break through uh on
the on the queen side the ones in the
special comes to C4 that's just it no
there's no attack happening and white is
just much much better on the king side
everything is coming forward so that's
why after Knight F5 Magnus tried Queen
to E8 but this also allows Hikaru a very
nice Knight captures and G7 Knight
captures and just strikes with F4 we
have B5 Magnus starts counter-attacking
on the queen side now Bishop captures on
C5 D captures in the D6 Hikaru frees up
the D5 Square for for uh his Knight C
Captain D6 and Knight to D5 so he gives
up a little bit of material uh leaves
his King vulnerable a little bit but he
gets um a very very nice counter play
now Knight F6 is a huge threat and
Magnus plays Queen to Da the best way to
pair in Knight F6 is Knight the H5 point
B being that if you play G4 then Knight
captures and F4 attacks the queen and
the Knight so you don't have to worry
about that and if you don't do this if
you do something like Queen F3 you guard
the G3 Pawn then Bush up the C6 attacks
the Knight and now even some nasty ideas
like Queen captures on H5 followed by
Knight F6 check can be met with the very
tricky Bishop captures and D5 and the
black is just better
but Magnus didn't find Knight to H5 he
played Queen to d8 and now we have F
characters and E5 Knight to E8 now
guarding the F6 square and E captures on
D6 we have B captures in C4 opening up
the B file for his Rooks Queen captures
on C4 and now Bishop to E6 and here uh
with E5 hikaru's position is Just a
Dream position but instead he goes Queen
captures on C5 and now uh Magnus plays
Knight captures on V6 but still if
Magnus found Rook to A5 this would be uh
still a very very tough game for for
both of them for example Queen to C3 now
you double up Rooks for free here you're
attacking the B2 pawn and if B4 let's
say a captures Bishop captures uh now
you can play Bishop characters on D5 and
after Rook captures only then Knight
captures on D6 that's how you win that
pawn but of course impossible to find in
Blitz uh Knight captures on D6 was
played right away and now it's Hikaru to
take everything for him himself he plays
E5 which isn't the most precise way but
it's but if you're interested Rook hdf1
uh incredibly difficult move to spot but
you will realize why uh in a second it
covers the F6 square and now look at
this if you attempt a rook day 5 now
which is basically Black's only Contra
play now you have Queen captures on D6
and after Queen captures Knight F6 check
and after King G7 Rook captures on D6
with your knight and F6 being defended
that's why Rook uh hdf1 is so strong but
of course who who spots this he he
respawn to E5 attacks the Knight and now
Magnus plays Rook to B5 attacks he he
carries Queen and now we have Knight the
F6 with track
uh King G7 uh he currently D5 with the
same idea he wants the F6 Square
protected but Rook F1 was a bit more
forcing Queen captures on D6 uh and here
again he gives Magnus the a way back
into the game the way you play this is
not capturing Knight but capturing the
rook and now the end game will be
winning Rook capture San Diego captures
and now Bishop capture 784 uh two
connected past pawns on the queen side
absolutely crushing for Hikaru but after
King G7 he played Queen captures on D6
and now he allows Magnus back into the
game but only if Magnus finds Queen to
C8 and uh okay Hikaru is not material
but Magnus is uh uh attacking and the
white king also isn't feeling all that
safe but after Queen capture Sandy six
we have Rook capture sund6 and now Rook
8 to B8 now it's a bit different because
Hikaru just plays a rook captures on E6
he gives back a little bit of material
but he's still gonna have a bishop and
Knight for a rook we have Rook captures
on B2 check King to C1 and F characters
on E6 and here just Rook to D1 and he
was in this position on move 34 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
Rook to D7 is coming and there is just
no good way to Parry this see if play
something like Rook to B7 then just
Bishop E4 and you can't defend both the
rook and the D7 Square so you have to
defend the rook and then comes Rook D7
check and then whatever King to f8 and
then you're just gonna capture on G6 and
there's no playing this you're either
getting checkmated or you're gonna
suffer severe material loss let's say
Throw cat person A2 Rook to F7 will be
Checkmate but any other move will also
be winning for Hikaru and that's why
Magnus resigned after Rook to D1
uh so yeah absolutely absolutely
incredible uh I can't uh even begin to
point out how incredible this match was
and okay this is only one game uh but if
you have three hours watch the full
three hours it will be a time very well
spent so yeah these are the uh the
results of all the formats of five plus
one three plus one and one plus one so
Hikaru uh uh got so far ahead in the
five plus one section that Magnus just
couldn't uh couldn't bounce back even
though he won the three plus one and the
one plus one section but Hikaru defends
his title uh and he defends it against
none other than world champion Magnus
Carlsen so Hikaru is the the speed chess
champion uh so yeah there we have it
hope you guys enjoyed it like I said
sorry about no videos for the past few
days but uh my my voice just didn't work
and I thought I'd just give it a rest
for a few days and then you know just um
uh continue probably during the world
rapid and Blitz Championship uh but yeah
some of you were worrying about my
health if I'm still around so yes I am
and I will be covering it uh so that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh I
would like to thank Samuel K and sang
Patrol of Bradley Campbell uh
Constantino solompridis and Jeffrey
Clayman for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
rapid and Blitz and checking up on your
wonderful suggestion do use hashtag
suggestions so I can spot your
suggestions a bit easier uh so yeah I
hope you enjoyed it thank you all and I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day